i kind of wanted to start from the angle
of uh like updates on the market because
i don't broadcast about this stuff
regularly i kind of peppered in through
my regular cast
i let guys know that i think
cryptocurrency is important it is part
of the future
and they should learn and get involved
with it uh there's miguel what's up
brother
hey what's going on rich hey man there
we go so we got everybody in the house
um yes so just to kind of get the ball
rolling here like where are we at with
things because
i don't know a few weeks ago elon elon
i'm on the spectrum musk you know some
about
bitcoin using too much energy and he's
dropping it now i just
like i can't believe this guy can move
the market like this much
and have this much influence and and
that many people you know think that
what he says and does should be taken as
gospel like he's a god but
there you have it um you know it seemed
to be the tipping point like the
catalyst like what are your guys
thoughts on all that
scaring the noobs uh the old money in
crypto
um is accumulating right and the uh
people on wall street are accumulating
i've had conversations with people who
work at the head offices
of jp morgan in new york as well as
morgan stanley through my consultations
over the last one month they're getting
in right they're all like
they're like frothing at the mouth with
these low prices on crypto right
and bloomberg i did a report uh uh that
they
i've showed a report that they did and i
did a deep dive on it uh
on tuesday on my show if you go over to
cultivate crypto and just
look at um bitcoin 20 000 or 100 000 and
2021 which is most likely
bloomberg is going uh towards 100 000
um for bitcoin specifically and more uh
not more than a hundred thousand but you
know higher prices for ethereum as well
and uh the the week before that i did a
report breakdown from goldman sachs uh
talking about
their bullish on bitcoin oh sorry
they're bullish on ethereum mainly
they don't like bitcoin as much uh
because it does threaten them quite a
bit
um but yeah i would say we're still
long-term bullish like
it's basically inevitable for cryptos so
you know we
with the mindset what we tell people is
when you come into crypto
and you don't know anything or you feel
like it's a lot of information at the
beginning
the best way to look at it first is as a
long-term savings account
so buy it intend to hold it for five
years right not touch it just money you
don't need for that period of time money
you need this year the next six months
next one year
keeping cash or something that you can
use right on a daily basis don't you
know
put in everything that you own um and
yeah if you look at it that way then
when you have these dips it's not really
emotional for you and then from there
then you can progress and learn along
the way but yeah
where we're at right now in the market
um it's basically accumulation time and
so bitcoin holding above 30k is very
bullish
and ethereum holding above 2000 is
bullish so those two levels holding
um everything's positive in that regard
you want to add to that to
uh miguel yeah sure just to go back onto
the elon musk's point right
yeah i mean one of the reasons why he
flipped so negatively on bitcoin
was because upcoming there's something
well
president biden has something called the
green new deal
which essentially is basically uh is
that all based on the aoc
thing yeah so it's a giant subsidy thing
for tesla
um solar solar wind it's pretty good you
know
anytime we can invest in renewables
that's pretty good but a big part of his
money was
uh he had a he had a kind of uh turn
coat real quick because the way tesla
makes a lot of their money is actually
selling uh
carbon tax credits over to other auto
auto manufacturers
because they're fully green and they
sell cars every car they sell they they
essentially
build up like a piggy bank of their
version of green credits or bitcoins
and then they sell those bitcoins off to
the other manufacturers that obviously
are not green at all and that's where
they make a lot of their money so they
were
threatened to lose that so that's why
they kind of turned coat and went real
green because
if they get those subsidies that they
need they can then
start paying for um essentially charging
centers all over the united states
as well as like um the reason i know for
sure bitcoin and all this stuff there's
people crying in the streets like
bitcoin's dead and everything it's all
over
doom and gloom right but you have his
one of his buddies
elon musk's buddies which is peter thiel
building the largest
solar farm in the united states in texas
right now for
just bitcoin mining alone and that's one
of the recipients are going to be
receiving those tax credits
for for bitcoin mining you had something
like these big players like celsius just
by 200 million dollar uh
what's called bitcoin mining operations
here in the states as well
so the bitcoin mining sector in the
united states is actually just getting
started right now
so this is uh not even el salvador
talking about mining
bitcoin with volcanoes now i love it
which is cool as hell right yeah
no they don't they they don't remember
bitcoin with volcanoes
renewable energy right 76 of bitcoin
uh miners right now are run on renewable
energy
so i mean you know people with that
argument just i didn't
i didn't really buy the whole you know
hype around it i was like oh
awesome it's on sale let's buy more um
and that's what i did you know i just
stacked more in the bags as
it kind of went down i even i even used
the london uh
b2x program which i know you can't get
in the us but there's parts of the world
that you can get it as well and they're
stacked up there with some other stuff
too
um so i'm still super bullish i mean i
was actually concerned at one point that
it might go below 30
000 but it doesn't look like it's going
that way anymore now it looks like it's
it's it's up on the climb uh it's at 37
408 as i speak right now um so that's
good
um what else what else has changed since
the last quarter since we talked last
i think one thing which was interesting
right looking at d5 and looking at the
amount of yield you can get i remember
when you
uh put this i think uh you put the link
for this channel
or for this stream up a while back and i
saw you uh take a screenshot of
yeah i quoted the vesper yield for it
was it like a thousand percent
during yeah and there were some guys
freaking out like oh it's a
snake oil salesman scam blah blah blah
it's like no dude
it's actually at that rate at that time
yeah i i think
the amount of coins that i had uh you
know getting
getting compounded doubled um per day um
during that time it went up to
as high as like 14 or 1500 percent um
yield you know if you were to average
that across the year that's what it
would end up at but you know you just
got it for that day or those couple of
days and it's been fluctuating obviously
but
when you get that compounding effect
happening with your crypto we did not
have that this last bull market right
yeah
i think that's something that amazed you
and i mentioned that i had a
it's at 48.15 right now
yeah yeah yeah exactly it does have wild
fluctuations but yeah i mean
getting a 40 yield on something is i
mean
all crazy in and of itself right it's
nothing you can get at a bank
um and i think i even mentioned this to
a
next hedge fund manager that i i met me
and john met him here
at the tokyo american club in tokyo the
other day and uh
he was i basically told that uh to him a
little bit about the percentage
that um we were making on that he was
just like are you freaking kidding me
like i need to learn about this you know
so you know the old guard
is uh you know they're starting to pay
attention i think and i think that's
important too
yeah um so what else have we seen change
since
since that last quarter that you guys
launched your course and you know by the
way guys if you want to get
in on the course uh they are opening it
up today i have sent an email to my list
with a link
already um it's also in the description
here i'll just drop it in live chat as
well if you want to grab in
um but what else has changed since the
last time you guys launched the course
with the uh market like what have you
learned since then like or what's been
proven or what's solidified or
become stronger basically the the
whole narrative there's this whole
narrative push right now that um
people are getting uh not not that
they're going negative on bitcoin but
there is there is
the very high likelihood that the
ethereum is going to get very close to
the
market cap on bitcoin even pass it yeah
you guys have been talking about the
flipping can you
can you expand on that yeah sure it's
this whole narrative of basically at
some point
ethereum's market cap not price per
token market cap is going to pass
bitcoin's market cap and go number one
and
uh this is a bitcoiner's nightmare
but it's one of the best times actually
to probably flip ethereum back into
bitcoin so it's actually a huge thing so
right now we're a little ethereum heavy
um and right
now currently you can get one ethereum
buys you
about seven percent of a bitcoin during
this peak time when this
flipping can happen either if it gets 80
or
actually passes it it's an opportunity
where you can get a ton of bitcoin
really
cheap and if you so choose after the
ethereum crashes you can then sell back
and get
a significantly large amount of ethereum
back or
just keep the bitcoin so it's a huge
huge opportunity so when you're talking
about the flipping
uh it says the market cap is just under
700 000 right now for bitcoin and
ethereum is 293
000. are you saying that the market cap
of ethereum
could potentially become more than
bitcoin during the sport bull run
yes yeah it can get i think the i would
i would call a success the flipping of
like
ethereum getting to eighty percent of
bitcoin's market cap which is
really high that's like an all like
pretty all-time high for the cycle
but during the flipping things what's
gonna happen is anytime if
let's just say ethereum were to pass
bitcoin for a bit what would happen is
you would have people
from the bitcoin side get very scared
and you know
no not these paper mache hands sell
their bitcoin
into ethereum which would pump ethereum
up
and then obviously we from there would
say that's not sustainable because it's
it just shot up too fast too quickly it
would be probably one of the best times
to actually sell ethereum into bitcoin
and you'd be able to get a significantly
large amount of bitcoin
and you guys cover all these strategies
and tactics in the course that you put
out i mean i've
i've been through the course material
twice now um they're all
live webinars and they run for two weeks
they're i mean they're about as in-depth
as
you know you could possibly want in fact
more than you probably want
um but it's still there right yeah
um i think you know people are still
like go quarter after quarter looking
back at the old recordings
even if they've come into multiple
courses right and use that as a way to
you know sometimes the course
information is
they're ready for a good chunk of it but
not all of it and then when they are
ready for it down
later down the road they still have
access to those videos quarter after
quarter so they can go back
and watch them over time as well
you